Well, let's make ourselves a little scratch room and work it out.
There are only 1, 2, 3 letters, a, b, and c involved,
so let's take a look at each one by one, see if it fits.
Suppose I was in state 2456 and I saw an a.
If I'm in 2 and I see an a I die, 4 and I see an a I die,
5 and I see an a I die, 6 and I see an a I die.
That's not good.
2456 on a goes to failure.
It does not go to 23.
All right, well, what if I see a b?
If I'm in 2 and I see a b, I go to 3. That looks pretty good.
4 and I see a b I die.
5 and I see a b I go to 2.
6 and I see a b I die.
Oh, b took us to exactly 2 and 3.
2456 on b went to 2 and 3.
But let's just finish checking up on c just in case we missed something.
I'm in 2456.
2 on a c goes nowhere.
4 on a c goes nowhere.
5 on a c goes to 6,
and 6 on a c goes nowhere, so 2456
on a c goes to 6.
Actually, we already have that edge, 2456 on a c goes to 6,
and since this machine is deterministic, we only want 1
outgoing edge here labeled c.
It looks like b was our winner.
The label for this edge is b.
Now, this is not a proof,
but it just so happens that any non-deterministic machine
can be converted to a deterministic machine
using exactly the same steps.